[Music]
fire
if taiko was trying to sneak out during
these times these specific times or it's
I do not leave your home policy he is
like 10 this right now it's pretty easy
to deal with tennis
the thing is tennis and he's used to
having a life outdoors like with his
friends and he's always like out and
about how would you get creative in ways
to make sure he doesn't sneak out and
leave your home too easy I just have him
stay in his room and then I'll just well
but the windows [ __ ] I've Nelson come
over this welding gun there's no way he
can open his my nose and the only way
for him to come out is through the door
but then I'm hanging out in the living
room so I'll see him come through the
living room you don't think he could
sneak by you at all not if I'm awake now
and then at night I already have locks
on the outside of his door so there's no
way you can open them from the inside
out I'll do a ball and chain old food
and his windows are sealed shut
well damn I would talk to my cats good
talking to you so much more advanced
recipe to talk to Loeb he can't walk it
so this is this little boy I've never
seen anyone it looks like that he look
like Huck up what over eyes [ __ ] up so
I don't know but this little boys who
were talking about here okay so he's
from the Philippines then looks like it
was like Geronimo or something I don't
know I don't know they barely just
blurred his eyes so this little boy he
was still sneaking out of his home in
the Philippines but he's a Filipino 10
year old that's very different from an
American ten year old I wanted to get
more guidelines to be like okay well
it's not like you can't really well
they're like whatever like you can't put
these restrictions I mean they can well
a Filipino ten-year-old could like
survive like way better than a thirty
year old American Crew I believe that is
already in the jungle yeah they got like
grown man skills at nine and [ __ ]
you brought a grown man skills because
this dad thought you know what this
little [ __ ] isn't listening to me he
needs to stay home so he can't see his
friends anymore
how am I gonna make him do that if he's
thinking out I'm gonna make him look
like an old man Bart gave me that
haircut yeah that's I look so sad
you want the sneak out down J Betar get
out let me show you what I'm going to do
you wanna be a young boy hat look you
wanna sneak out you want to be a big man
huh it's a clean shave it is so clean oh
like how do you not have any follicles
like showing at all Wow yes now these
sneaks how you look stupid as [ __ ]
doesn't want to do it that's pretty
smart you can wear a hat you completely
normal normal also it's like for them
it's like they sneak out they go to a
little park here it's fine for any of us
and your kids have to walk hell a
[ __ ] far because they can't drive
they came over they're gonna walk 20
miles they don't know they get driven
here but they don't know where to go ya
know that's not true
I think Isaac knows how to get around
because ever since he was so little
remember what you'd be like isn't home
that way like really she was really
glory nted he's a hunter boy I already
know that for me it was more like mom
you serve me does ya know for some
reason like he always knew where he was
and where I'm like that's [ __ ] tight I
don't have that skill I never had a
problem with directions either as a kid
like I even got in trouble because I
went to Thailand one time and to
celebrate I wanted to go run around the
city and I was about 13 years old by
myself
yeah and I got lost like a [ __ ]
and I found my way back and I was like I
know what I was doing but in my heart I
was like God Jesus
[Laughter]
and then when they thought I was like
couches on a run and they're like you
were called for it like so long we're
all worried for you why did you do that
and I'm not all you know I just wanted
to celebrate a jog like cuz it's New
Years
you're so lucky they found you what we
do I found I found my way back okay like
I was assuming that like America
everything is built like like a grid
like a grid yeah like a [ __ ] like a
straight up rectangle so I was just
gonna go around the city as a whole city
block like this but the way that the
city's design out there it's all [ __ ]
twisty and turny and it's crazy but I
found my way back
Wow yeah that's how I feel when I play
minecraft and I die somewhere in the
middle of the map and I'm like [ __ ] I
lost my map and then I find it and I get
really happy you're like I've built the
treehouse damn I didn't follow tree
house everyone talks about their kids
they're like them when they're I was
such a good kid
really it was a little bit I respected
my parents I was obviously like like a
little kid at a high energy you do
whatever but like my friends like you
can't do that you can't do that didn't
really older brother I'm rebellious and
maybe you saw your holder brother get
punished oh I don't want to do that no I
think he never snuck out when you're a
teenager no wow are you really good you
weren't impulsive as a kid I always
wanted to have Steve along and say no so
I wouldn't I would ask until they beat
me to shut the [ __ ] up oh I mean that
happened but I still listen I didn't
just be like I [ __ ] you I'm gonna do my
own thing man that's tight I I mean I'm
saying this and I hope it's true and I
hope I don't drinks myself but I think
Isaac's like that dude I think so I
think he's like that look at him
sometimes and I'm all like you need to
break some more rules boy no he doesn't
cuz I look at him and I'm like him and
me at his age I'm like this is cuz if if
I was your son and you're my mom or
embodied in Isaac I'm like TIFF would
even be able to concentrate during JK
knees because she'd be getting a phone
call every hour from the principal my
mom told me she had PTSD so my mom she's
part of like this thing called the
equipment control which is making sure
all the trucks
getting places at times and so she does
have to pick up the phone but says she's
getting a phone call from the school she
doesn't know if it's cool if it's cool
her [ __ ] like her job so even till
this day she told me like when she hears
a phone ring that she gets like this
what the [ __ ] that part doing now she
blames your ass and she was the [ __ ]
parent yeah I have noticed like a
pattern like if Isaac's does start
acting up we can and we you know sitting
down to like talk like we can usually
trace it back to something that we did
as yeah I kind of like rubbed in the
wrong way or wasn't fully explained or
like he just kind of like like is like I
mentioned attention so he needs to do
something to get our attention and like
yeah we did your mom and dad I talk to
you a lot true how'd they get too big no
it just was are all of you guys your
older brother good and her little sister
good too uh maybe they're scarier than
our parents like what happens Thank You
Troy no I mean it was just it was it was
fine I feel like they they they're like
just don't do that because that people
are out they did explain that because
because a lot of parents are just like
just don't do that especially a lot of
minority parents yeah
and I was just like okay you know how
was it that's cool I think maybe that's
why I good cuz we I mean I try our best
to explain like the reasons why we're
telling him these things and he seems to
and we're always asking like do you get
it like do you have any questions like
does that make sense but our friends now
they're like I don't say the name but
like the going out drink this whole
thing about yo stop going out like doing
this you're tight enough you literally
got shot last month and you got hit
because you're being stupid and I do I
should say some names shame up just give
me but that was like dude you can't keep
doing this especially now it's like
you're gonna get people's sake you're
gonna gave you when you go back home you
need parent sick they're like [ __ ]
your Louis I don't know whose friend is
so pretty close yeah so
you only live once it's only think I am
I'm is yes but some people just can't
listen and it's not what you tell them
you know just like what they just think
our aim is also their friends and what
they see online can more so have an
effect on other parents I don't think
beating if I wanted something I will get
it no matter what until I face the
consequences and I'm like that is why
you don't do graffiti the beating jail
or like you know like you do some stupid
[ __ ] and it's every tip to to everyone
it's like awful like that is why you
don't talk smack to people that could
[ __ ] you up cuz they'll [ __ ] you up
right but then like if you if I was the
kind of guy that would just keep pushing
and do whatever the [ __ ] I want until I
got my ass beat or until I got caught by
cops or it always was the worst thing
happening like even with my experience
with drugs until I had a traumatic
experience I was like all that is why
you don't do so much drugs like it gets
scary and then I don't want to do it
anymore
that's what I was like too because I was
getting in trouble just a little bit and
then my mom would punish me before the
school even play so some of my mom's
logic is if I'm stricter than my son my
son then school is then he will never
even mess up so that school or the law
will get to him right because he's being
way more controlled but because I never
feel real consequences I'm only feeling
the consequences of my mom will just get
my ass beat it made me want to keep
going until I actually felt legal
consequences or school consequences are
you so curious I never learned a lesson
how bad can it really be is that what
you thought are looking back at you're
like that's what you do I think as a kid
you're like kind of impulsive and just
doing your own [ __ ] so subconsciously
you don't know what the hell's I don't
know what you're doing with your kid
you're just doing it you know and then
but there now looking back I'm like I
think I needed to really learn like oh
this is what I feel like to get kicked
out of score when I liked when you
really get arrested together for you you
feel like the way things happen to you
is the only way it could have made you
understand like so if you were your own
parent how would you have parented
yourself I think for me it's it's kind
of like a two-fold thing where not only
was there no explanation and there's
also just these cuts
winces from my mom before I got to the
real consequence it was like a double
whammy but I think even if my mom wanted
to be really strict but she had good
explanations for things I think I don't
think I would have turned out the way I
did at that time I just needed someone
to explain some [ __ ] to me but I think
my mom she was like a single parent was
just probably stressed out and so she
probably didn't know how to think
herself and again communicate yeah just
do this just go and do this you know and
then so it was just kind of like it was
those two things that created this why
don't know what the [ __ ] going on so
I've got to go fend for myself because
that's what my mom said is that she
didn't even know why she was following
the rules that she followed so it was
embarrassing because she couldn't come
up with the solution or the explanation
so she just shut me up I [ __ ] me up
and then so but that thought I incepted
her and and then she says it would like
she wouldn't be able to sleep at night
with the things and questions that I had
and she's like why did I never even
think of this well about life and
whatever she says she held that for like
30 40 years oh and I didn't know any of
that a long time to hold something
that's like that keep her awake for a
night well yeah cuz she was going
through like a [ __ ] I guess wooden
like a red pill moment or whatever you
know where she was just like what this
is what I'm blowing like how could this
kid be asking these questions and I
don't know the answer like how come I
just live life believing everything that
Authority told me yeah because I was
just curious yeah you're inquisitive and
yeah and my mind was just like oh why
didn't even go to school right and then
I think all kids they discover [ __ ] this
way they'll go why I need a school cuz
you need a job why didn't you a job oh
you need a job so you could work and
provide for your family lighting to have
a family like you ask these questions as
a kid you ain't broke your mom in the
sense where you made a rule answers life
crisis but I would get deeper though
because I would go like West world like
she was like yeah matrix so a normal kid
would say stuff like that right and but
I would say stuff like basically the the
the the Western world had the
Renaissance but the eastern world never
had that or never had logic and
philosophy so that's why we didn't
involve the same way in Asia and then so
my dad was like so mind blown at that
he says you you think Asians are
as good as white people and he beat me
up and I was like that's not even what I
was saying I was just saying that the
societies evolved different with
philosophy I didn't say it in those
words though because I had a limited
vocabulary fourth or fifth grade oh but
that's the kind of questions I would
give to them and ask them and that they
took that as rebellion and backtalk and
I was just trying to have like a
discussion and that's when I thought
they were dumb because it's like you
can't have discussions and you just [ __ ]
me up because you don't know the answer
but they couldn't think like that back
then either I don't think so they
weren't allowed to especially because we
were devoutly religious I just imagined
all having worse tack than he does now
so the coin was worse yes it was even
about race you know but like yeah he
think that's what he took it as
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]